أريد فقط أن أذهب إلى CNN Scaris الآن
Scannell الذي خرج من
قاعة المحكمة وصف ما
سمعته ورأيته في المحكمة بينما نستمر في
النظر في لوائح الاتهام
عندما دخل الرئيس السابق قاعة
المحكمة ، يمكنك سماع قطرة دبوس
دخلها  قام بمسح كل صف
مليء بالمراسلين وكان لديه القليل
من العبوس على وجهه ، مشى
ببطء شديد إلى طاولة الدفاع ثم
لم يتحدث حتى طلب منه القاضي
تقديم طلب بشأن هذه التهم الـ 34 الخاصة
بتزوير السجلات التجارية  بالدرجة الأولى
وقال الرئيس السابق في
صوته إننا جميعًا نعلم أننا غير مذنبين
الآن ، كما طلب القاضي المدعون من القاضي
معالجة الخطاب الذي
أدلى به الرئيس السابق من خلال
الهجمات الكلامية التي وجهها إلى
القاضي وكذلك  قال المدعي العام
ألفين براج والقاضي إنك
تعلم أنه كان قلقًا بشأن هذه
التصريحات ، وقال محامي دونالد ترامب
تود بلانش الذي انضم للتو إلى الفريق
إن ترامب محبط
وأنه لم تتح له الفرصة لمعالجة
كل هذه الأمور.  المزاعم بأن
النيابة العامة وشهودهم
بما في ذلك مايكل كوهين قد خرجوا
وتحدثوا علنًا لكن القاضي
قال إنه لا يوافق على أن هذا كان
مبررًا بالإحباط وقال إنه
سيحذر كلا الجانبين من
الادعاء ودونالد ترامب للتكفل بذلك.
خفض خطابهم أنه لن
يفرض أي نوع من أوامر منع النشر لكنه
حذرهم أيضًا من أنهم بحاجة إلى معالجة
هذا من أجل التهدئة وعدم التحريض على أي
عنف